heute wird es wirklich spannend leute
100 mal stärker als die stärkste
eruption der sonne eine zitat wahnsinnig
große eruption haben gleich mehrere
instrumente auf dem stern proxima
centauri beobachtet tatsächlich einen
rekord ausbruch bei dem der sternen
ultravioletten spektrum um das 14
tausendfache heller wurde
doch die merkmale des ausbruchs setzen
die fachleute vor ein rätsel
bedeutet diese beobachtung nun das
endgültige aus für potentielles leben im
umfeld von proxima centauri klicks um
sein sind future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
es handelt sich um den stärksten aus
wovon proxima centauri den
forschungsteams je eingefangen haben am
ersten mai 2009 10 war es so weit wie
die fachleute jetzt in einer aktuellen
studie berichten im radio in
millimeterwellen bereich stieg die
helligkeit des roten zwergs abrupt an
und zwar um das tausendfache zu der
spektakulären premiere sagt die
astrophysikerin meredith mcgregor der
stern wurde im ultravioletten nicht
plötzlich 14.000 mal heller in der
vergangenheit wussten wir nicht einmal
das sterne bei ihren ausbrüchen auch im
millimeterbereich strahlen dies ist das
erste mal dass wir einen stern ausbruch
in einer so großen spektralen bandbreite
beobachtet haben
es handelt sich also wirklich um eine
rekordverdächtige energie freisetzung
und das obwohl der gesamte zeitraum des
ausbruchs weniger als zehn sekunden
dauerte die aktuelle analyse der
forschungsteams aber offenbart dass
alleine in dieser kurzen zeitspanne
allein im uv bereich eine energie von
1030 erk das ist eine maßeinheit für
energie freigesetzt wurde
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in
millimeter und fern und v bereich des
spektrums ist dies der stärkste jemals
von proxima centauri beobachtete flair
doch der registrierte aus pur ist nicht
nur besonders rekordverdächtig sondern
zeigt auch einige merkmale die uns vor
ein großes rätsel stellen wie kann
dieser ausruf erklärt werden und was
bedeutet die heftigkeit der energie
freisetzung für potentielles
außerirdisches leben und die lebens
freundlichkeit der planeten um proxima
centauri die
antworten auf diese spannenden fragen
gibt es gleich hier in diesem video
proxima centauri 1 rote zwergsterne
unser nächster nachbar im all für
künftige raummissionen sind vor allem
seine beiden planeten die nur vier
lichtjahre von der erde im fernsehen
spannend heißt also als sonnen extra
stern ist proxima centauri schon seit
längerer zeit im visier der fachleute er
gehört zu der klasse von stern in der
milchstraße die wohl mit abstand am
häufigsten sind schätzungen zufolge sind
drei viertel aller sterne rote zwerge
und gemeint sind damit die kleinsten und
noch aktiven sterne
sie weisen nur etwa 1 bis 7 zehntel der
sonnenmasse auf und so läuft die
kernfusion im inneren der roten zwerge
eher auf sparflamme heißt also im
klartext rote sterne produzieren wenig
energie ihre oberflächentemperatur liegt
nur bei 2400 bis 3.700 calvin und das
entspricht in etwa der temperatur des
glühfaden seiner vintage glühbirne heißt
also es handelt sich um stern die
ziemlich schwach auf der brust sind und
selbst unser nachbar stern proxima
centauri ist so lichtschwach dass wir
ihn mit bloßem auge nicht erkennen
können obwohl er so nah an uns dran ist
doch die roten sterne sind außerdem auch
bekannt dafür dass sie besonders aktiv
sind rote zwerge weisen also eine extrem
hohe solare aktivität auf die zu einer
starken strahlenbelastung führt die rede
ist von der sogenannten flair aktivität
diese flairs meinen grob gesagt
aktivitäten auf der oberfläche die von
der so genannten contact even schicht
herrühren elektrisch leiten das plasma
bewegt sich und erzeugt elektrische
ströme die dann wiederum zu
magnetfeldern führen sobald eine
magnetische zone instabil wird wird die
im magnetfeld gespeicherte energie
schlagartig frei und das führt zu einem
auswurf von plasma in den weltraum
flairs produzieren also riesige mengen
an extremer uv-strahlung solche flyers
gibt es bei manchen roten zwergen alle
paar jahre nicht so aktiv sind sie bei
roten zwergen die langsam rotieren und
verhältnismäßig jung sind die meisten
roten zwerg sterne aber sind sehr aktiv
deutlich aktiver als sonnenähnliche
sterne und das führt dazu dass die
umliegenden planeten oft mit einer hoch
energetischen strahlung geflutet werden
und diese strahlung ist wirklich extrem
sie ist nicht nur in der lage vorhanden
eine atmosphären zu zerstören auch die
dann völlig ungeschützt oberfläche
dieser planeten könnte durch sie
angegriffen werden
der stern proxima centauri wird von zwei
planeten umkreist und einer davon ist
laut fachleuten potenziell ehrt ähnlich
und befindet sich in der sogenannten
habitablen zone doch schon seit längerer
zeit diskutieren fachleute weltweit wie
lebensfreundlich dieser eher zwillingen
wirklich ist denn die strahlen ausbrüche
mit denen er traktiert wird sind
wirklich heftig und jetzt nicht gerade
optimal für leben bereits einige
mächtige eruptionen vom proxima centauri
wurden in der vergangenheit
aufgezeichnet den ausbruch am ersten mai
vor zwei jahren hatten gleich fünf
teleskope gleichzeitig festgehalten
dabei waren unter anderem das
weltraumteleskop hubble das riesige alma
teleskop der europäischen südsternwarte
eso und sogar der exo planeten jäger
test für transit exoplanet survey
satellite der nasa insgesamt waren das
sogar neue teleskope die gleichzeitig
rund 40 stunden auf proxima centauri
gerichtet waren die fachleute um die
forscherinnen meredith mcgregor von der
university of colorado veröffentlichen
ihre ergebnisse dazu jetzt im
fachmagazin astrophysical journal
letters
die energie freisetzung die beobachtet
wurde war rekordverdächtig wie am anfang
des videos erwähnt stieg die helligkeit
des roten zwergs im radio und
millimeterwellen bereich abrupt an und
zwar um das tausendfache doch zwei
andere beobachtung stellen die fachleute
vor ein rätsel
zum einen konnte im sichtbaren bereich
des lichts nur ein minimaler anstieg der
helligkeit registriert werden
so stiegen diese werte bei test- und nur
rund 0,9 prozent an
und auch eine weitere beobachtung lässt
die forschungsteams stützen der strahlen
puls im sichtbaren licht erreichte erst
mit einer minute verzögerung seine
höhepunkt dazu schreibt das team
diese merkmale wurden noch nie zuvor bei
einem solchen zwerg stern beobachtet es
spricht dafür dass wir hier eine ganz
neue art von ereignissen sehen die
fachleute vermuten dass eine art
kurzschluss in den magnetfeldlinien
dahinter steckt denn stellare strahlen
ausbrüche kommen typischerweise zustande
wenn sich die magnetstreifen
beispielsweise an der sonnenoberfläche
erst verdienen
und dann plötzlich aufreißen eine art
magnetischer kurzschluss also bei dem
gigantische energiemengen frei werden
das heißt plasma der sonnenoberfläche
wird dann in folge als sogenannter
koronaler massenauswurf ins all
geschleudert möglicherweise ist ein
ähnlicher vorgang auch bei proxima
centauri abgelaufen die rede ist hier
von einer magnetischen re kollektion ein
physikalisches phänomen bei denen sich
die struktur eines magnetfelds abhob
ändert große energiemengen freigesetzt
werden und elektronen dadurch
beschleunigt werden
das alles könnte den anfänglichen
strahlen schub im radio und tv bereich
erklären so zumindest die vermutung der
fachleute die optische strahlung die er
leicht verzögert abgegeben wurde führt
das forschungsteam auf das erhitzte
plasma am fuß der magnetstreifen zurück
diese ganzen neuen erkenntnisse bedeuten
für potentielles leben auf den
exoplaneten vom proxima centauri
möglicherweise nichts gutes so die
fachleute
denn proxima centauri ist ähnlich alt
wie unsere sonne und seine planeten
werden deswegen wahrscheinlich schon
seit milliarden jahren mit energie
reißen flairs bombardiert und die
kurzwellige und daher besonders
energiereiche strahlung ist für
ungeschützte lebewesen tödlich also
zumindest für die form von leben die uns
von der erde bislang bekannt ist dazu
sagt die astrophysikerin meredith
mcgregor wenn es leben auf dem planeten
gibt der proxima centauri am engsten
umkreis müsste es ganz anders aussehen
als alles was wir von der erde kennen
ein mensch auf diesem planeten hätte ist
ziemlich schwer
erst anfang dieses jahres 2021 erschien
eine us-studie mit neuen
forschungsergebnissen zu potenziellen
außerirdischen leben im umfeld der
sogenannten roten zwerge den nachkommen
diese für außerirdisches leben sehr wohl
in frage
und das obwohl es dort immer mal wieder
heftige strahlungs ausbrüche gibt das os
forschungsteam hatte mit hilfe von 3d
simulationen analysiert wie sie es
solche flairs auf die atmosphärenchemie
vom planeten innerhalb der habitablen
zone auswirken
die studie kommt zu einem überraschenden
ergebnis demnach ist solch ein extremes
weltraumwetter nicht das zwangsläufige
aus für die entstehung und die
entwicklung von leben
bei der analyse wurde die
atmosphärenchemie derjenigen planeten
untersucht die solchen ausbrüchen
ausgesetzt sind die ergebnisse wurden
dann mit planeten verglichen die eben
keine oder nur schwaches solare
aktivität mitbekommen dazu sagt der
forscher howard chen der an der us
studie beteiligt war
tatsächlich können gerade auch
fortwährende flairs eines sterns die
atmosphärische zusammensetzung eines
planeten in ein neues gleichgewicht
bringen aus diesem grund schließen
stellare ausbrüche auch nicht per se die
existenz von leben auf dem planeten aus
in einigen fällen führen selbst stetige
fluss nicht dazu etwa die gesamte
planetare ozonschicht aufzulösen leben
auf dortigen oberflächen hätte also
weiterhin eine chance
und nicht nur das das os forschungsteam
kam weiterhin zu dem ergebnis dass
flairs sogar hilfreich für unsere suche
nach außerirdischem leben sein könnten
denn sie könnten es erleichtern dieses
leben aufzuspüren und zu detektieren
dazu das team so können die lage flairs
den anteil eventuell vorhandener gase
die auf leben hinweisen von einem
unmerklichen auf ein nachweisbares
niveau anheben die simulation legen also
nahe dass strahlen ausbrüche die
entstehung die entwicklung von
außerirdischen leben nicht per se
ausschließen ganz im gegenteil dieses
weltraumwetter könnte sogar dazu
beitragen dass forschungsteams weltweit
die signaturen von chemischen biomarkern
auf einem planeten besser identifizieren
können übrigens das signal aus proxima
centauri das seit monaten für aufregung
sorgt und über das wir natürlich auch
hierbei klicks um science and future
berichtet haben wird weiter analysiert
manche fachleute hoffen dass es sich
hierbei tatsächlich um das erste
künstliche signal einer außerirdischen
zivilisation handelt entdeckt wurde es
mit hilfe des parks radioteleskops in
australien und zwar im rahmen eines
strahlungsausbruch vom proxima centauri
der harvard astronomie wie loeb hatte
sich bislang skeptisch dazu geäußert und
mehrere punkte aufgelistet die seiner
meinung nach im großen und ganzen
dagegen sprechen dass es sich hier um
signale einer außerirdischen
zivilisation handelt klar ist aber
unsere nachbar system einen besuch
abzustatten wären mehr als hilfreich und
pläne dazu gibt es schon längst
ein projekt der breakthrough initiative
namens star schott will miniatur sonden
mit licht segeln antreiben und so
innerhalb von 20 jahren proxima centauri
erreichen
mitinitiator löw sieht vor allem den
planeten proxima b
als mögliche heimat einer möglichen
außerirdischen zivilisation
vielleicht befindet sich also wirklich
direkt neben uns kosmischen maßstab
außerirdisches leben das wäre doch total
auf meine last comics tv habe ich euch
noch mehr über das mysteriöse alien
signal aus proxima centauri berichtet
klickt dafür einfach mal auf das
angezeigte video
außerdem freue ich mich natürlich riesig
wenn ihr meinen channel asto comics tv
abonniert erhaltet dort mehrmals
wöchentlich aktuelle infos über
wissenschaft und weltraum und könnte mir
total helfen man ziel von 60.000 autos
zu erreichen vielen vielen dank heute
wir sehen uns im nächsten video bis dann
bleibt dran